so you're just gonna stroll in here
looking like actual royalty like a real
life royalty with this come on now you
look great that's really generous of you
i'm very lucky to work with brilliant
people i'm also hugely lucky to be
wearing fendi couture by my great old
friend
mr kim jones
so it's down to the team i'm afraid
so you have
a great deal of experience with
fandom fans who love what you're doing
fans who love which are in who are
intensely interested and scrutinize all
the details this is a particular project
that people have been waiting for for a
very very long time what was it like to
actually be able to say we did it we
made this happen
it it was a huge undertaking and i think
that
neil has obviously
really cared about how this project's
been depicted and alan heinberg whose
work i really deeply admired in wonder
woman i thought the script was brilliant
and i thought who is that voice that's
an extraordinary voice he has
has loved it and it's been such genuine
care and respect for the material that
people have worked really really hard on
going the extra mile to feel like
somehow the essence of the comic has
come about onto our screens
for you
between the words on the page and
putting the costume on and the hair and
being on set when do you feel like
you've clicked into character
it's only ever
when i first start speaking
okay only then only then because before
then it's all practice we had an
incredible creative experience on this i
think we worked on it for about six
months before we actually filmed
i was very lucky my partner the designer
giles deacon designed my costumes
through a conversation with neil with
alan
um with our brilliant costume designer
sarah arthur we all worked
very hard to make this come about and uh
and graham who did hair and makeup we
everybody worked together it was very
much a collaborative effort and
i still used even though i also i worked
with a phenomenal movement coach called
harry alexander and we'd worked on
lucifer's movements and
and who lucifer was but still it is only
in that moment when you first speak that
you feel that
maybe there's some life
has come into the character
maybe maybe
but lucifer is
one of the most intriguing characters in
the cast of like
incredible ethereal elemental characters
how did you make lucifer
how did you embody
who lucifer is for you
well i
this part came about at a really
interesting time um with the landscape
of global events we're all having to
live through and and the enforced time
of confinement i think that
we've all
been doing these inventories of
ourselves and who we are how we live
and
unfortunately it felt like
manifestations of
negativity or
evil were more abound than ever
so
it was
it was timely
you